welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and perhaps the most upsetting
reveal in loki episode 1 was that loki's
glorious purpose of the infinity stones
was only worth its weight in
paperweight the infinity stones weren't
just loki's obsession they were the
crucial namesake of marvel's entire
infinity saga sought after by thanos the
avengers guardians of the galaxy
asgardians and sorcerers black widow
died and risked making her long-awaited
solo film less relevant to get one of
these paperweights
so did iron man and thanos black widow
gamora vision
sacred timeline loki heimdall and luke's
arm really die for nothing if the tva
has a drawer full of duplicate infinity
stones sliding around
loose with the silverware no i am here
to tell you that these stones weren't
just to rattle loki's pride and
certainly not to make a joke out of the
infinity saga
but as key symbols explaining how the
tva
operates in relationship with the rest
of the mcu the first episode of loki
does such a good job reverting loki's
character development to that
villainous pride and ambition that
defined him back in the first avengers
film like notice how immediately after
scooping the avengers and escaping to
mongolia the first thing he does
is to try to assert dominance to these
random villagers
i am loki of asgard
and i am burdened with glorious purpose
these same words this guy had just
uttered to nick fury when he arrived to
steal the tesseract i am loki
of asgard and i am burdened with
glorious purpose
but by the end of this episode that
pride is shattered when loki scrambles
to retrieve the tesseract only to
realize that in the tba
infinity stones are a dime a dozen how
do you have these
oh we actually got a lot of those yeah
some of the guys use them as paper
weights
some of them but notice how loki briefly
palms a time stone perhaps the stone he
was most eager to acquire someday
remember that and then loki hopes is
this the greatest power in the universe
and then b-15 rushes in and erases all
of these stones
inside casey's evidence card as loki
gives up his glorious purpose but not
out of respect of the tva's illogical
laws but really out of acceptance that
the infinity stones are not the key to
his glorious future that he thought they
would be
even an infinity stone is useless here
tva is formidable but before we continue
thanks to keeps for sponsoring this
video losing your hair can be a bummer
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're 35
i know guys in my life that are really
stressed out about it but with keeps
it's easier and more affordable to get
treatment for your hair loss and help
you keep the hair that you have
keeps offers generic versions of the
only two fda approved hair loss products
out there but at half the cost of your
local pharmacy
though you'll never have to go into a
doctor's office with keeps you get 24
7 access to a doctor who designs the
best plan for you they offer other
helpful tools and services including a
tracking tool so you can monitor your
progress
find out why keep says more five-star
reviews than any of its competitors and
nearly 100 000 men
trust keeps for their hair loss
prevention medication so if you're ready
to take action and prevent hair loss go
to keeps.com
new rockstars or click the link in the
description to receive 50
off your first order that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash new rockstars
so as loki asks how does the tva get
these duplicate infinity stones
by casey saying we get a lot of these i
think he's saying they confiscated these
from past detained variants like notice
how the other items
in the drawer include a french medal of
honor and the most valuable baseball
card in the world
and u-92 theorized that the oklahoma
nexus event was someone trying to get
rich off oil so really i think the idea
is that infinity stones are just one of
many treasures that others before loki
have skewed from their sacred timeline
to try to obtain
now before the ancient one seemed to
indicate that only infinity stone
removal could create a branch timeline
but now according to miss minutes
something as simple as checking in late
the work could create a next event which
sounds nuts and based on rich prick
martin
it sounds like individuals making the
wrong choice happens all the time with
all kinds of people
and each time it happens the time
keepers sound the alarm the tva swoops
in they detain the variant they prune
the branch and they erase that variant
but i think that also means they keep
whatever loot that variant was after and
after doing this countless times
duplicate infinity stones have
piled up but how can multiple infinity
stones exist in the same time and space
like by the look of it it looks like we
had
five reality stones in there well
according to everything we had been told
about the infinity stones they seemed to
be these sacred constants that embodied
elemental aspects of the universe power
space reality soul time and mind and
together they maintained the proper flow
of time
so much so that the endgame directors
had to clarify that when thanos used the
stones to destroy the stones the stones
were in fact
atomized so that their presence still
exists in the universe just incapable of
being weaponized so that also means that
when the avengers returned from the time
heist with those stolen infinity stones
in the present those stones
were duplicates existing simultaneously
in the present mcu
with the atomized stone mist after
thanos's garden snap so by that rule
multiple stone variants can co-exist
in a single place and time so long as
before too long those variants are
returned
so does that make the infinity stones
worthless
in the tva yes but outside the tva hell
no
because the tva exists outside the
sacred timeline it's in the null time
zone the end credits actually suggest it
could be in some in-between space
between some of the nine realms
everything the tva detains and brings
inside the tva
are variants of a prime equivalent
in the sacred timeline which goes on
undisturbed so
when the tva arrested loki variant l1130
there still existed the original prime
loki
in the sacred timeline who went back
with thor to asgard and went through the
events of the dark world and ragnarok
and infinity war but the moment this
loki picked up the tesseract he
spawned a variant timeline of variant
loki a variant tesseract that didn't
steal the tesseract or steal the loki
out of the sacred timeline those are
still there
so when a variant infinity stones branch
is pruned
the variant stone loses its power its
glow fades a bit but when the avengers
stole variant stones from the past
those stones kept their power because
those branches had not yet been pruned
by cat meanwhile each of the stones here
in the drawer were
variant duds from other previously
pruned branches but despite these being
duds
those six prime infinity stones remain
in the sacred timeline fully powered
waiting to be found and used by the
avengers and thanos in the history we've
seen and then inevitably atomized by
thanos in the sacred timeline so
all of the sacrifices made by the
avengers made by thanos are still
every bit as meaningful and the effects
those stone use is left on the world
still every bit is consequential when
loki bemoans
even and infinity stone is useless here
he's really using the stone as a
metaphor for his own uselessness but
what mobius is trying to get at is
this tva confined powerlessness doesn't
erase the other loki in the sacred
timeline
the reason why he makes loki watch his
favorite highlights is because there are
lessons to be learned from that story so
the history of the infinity saga is not
being erased by loki it's informing this
next step and the way that the tva has
to find a new purpose for variant
infinity stones be it paperweights or
lining fish tanks despite not knowing
what fish are so
too must variant loki find a new
glorious purpose meanwhile let's
remember
casey's words there some of the guys use
them as paper weights
some of them yeah he's not just making a
joke there the end credits show a mind
stone being used as a paperweight so
that also makes us wonder what he meant
by
some of them did someone else go rogue
and use a variant infinity stone for
some other purpose
in the past theoretically if you could
track down one of these variant stones
source branch and if that branch either
wasn't fully pruned or if it were able
to get
reformed that stone might reactivate if
taken
back to that branch so let's keep in
mind loki fiddling with that time stone
there now it sounded like it clunked
back down in the drawer
but if he might have slightly pocketed
it before b15
erased that cart the way he pocketed
mobius's time twister
so sneakily that time stone might come
in handy someday hey you can support
this channel by checking out our new
loki inspired merch options like the
shirt loki out of time
by going to newrockstarsmerch.com follow
me on instagram and twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars and subscribe to
new rockstars loki breakdowns
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you